JEREMY STERN: Good afternoon.
I'm Jeremy Stern
with Google Fiber,
and welcome to today's
Authors Talks at LAX.
And thanks for
joining us here in LA.
I also want to welcome our
Googlers who are joining us
via GVC from all
over the country--
New York City,
Irvine, Playa Vista,
Chicago, Austin,
Kansas City, Sunnyvale,
and even MTV, Mountain View.
I'm super excited to introduce
our Author Talk today,
for a number of reasons.
First, Susan Packard is an
extraordinary leader and media
innovator.
As co-founder of HGTV and
as COO of Scripps Networks
International, she
built HGTV into one
the most widely distributed
cable networks in the country,
100 million households
plus, and turned it
into a multi-billion
dollar business.
So as author of "New
Rules of the Game,"
she has a lot to
share with us today
about competing and
leading successfully
in today's workplace.
It's also a pleasure,
a deep pleasure,
for me to introduce Susan
as a dear friend of mine.
I've known her for decades,
since the earliest,
my earliest, days
in the industry.
And I knew back then
she was special.
The way she created
lasting partnerships
and win-win scenarios for
her distribution partners
was extraordinary.
And though she
lives in Tennessee,
a long ways from here-- I
don't see her frequently,
but it's truly a blessing
that our friendship always
picks up where it left off.
So let me turn it over to Susan.
And after the talk, we'll take
questions from the audience.
And for those of you
in remote offices,
if you'd like to ask Susan a
question, feel free to ping me,
and I'll try to weave it in.
So, Susan, welcome.
SUSAN PACKARD: Thanks, Jeremy.
Thank you.
Hello, everyone, and
everyone remotely.
I asked Jeremy when I walked in.
He showed me around
a little bit.
And I said, how's it feel to
be everybody's father here?
And he said-- so I'm
thinking to myself,
maybe if I just become
your favorite aunt,
this will all work really well.
But it's true.
We've known each
other quite a while.
I thought I'd start with a
little bit about my background
beyond what Jeremy
had said, because it
gets into why I wrote the book.
So I've been in the world
of media my whole career.
I left the corporate world
of media four years ago.
I'm a builder, an
entrepreneur, by nature,
which I know you
can all relate to,
and had been on the ground floor
of some formidable brands--
HBO, CNBC, MSNBC, and then
all the Scripps brands
that I helped to co-found.
And I found myself at
Scripps for 16 years,
which was amazing to me.
It went by quickly.
And I felt the need to
just start something new,
so I left four years ago.
And at the same time,
a friend of mine,
who's written some
business books,
said, you know,
Susan, you might want
to write about
your career story,
because it's an interesting one.
And that had me standing
back and thinking,
what were all the factors that
helped to influence my getting
into top posts in companies?
And that's what the
book's all about.
It works.
"New Rules of the Game,"
this is not just my story,
but I interviewed a dozen
CEOs, mostly women but some men
as well.
And all of our stories
are woven into this book.
And it all works
under this uber idea
that I call
gamesmanship, which is
a way of expressing
your competitive spirit
in a healthy way.
And I'll get into that when
we get into the chapters.
So I was a kid raised
in the Midwest.
And I was born with this
enormous competitive drive.
But God's sorry joke
on me, I did not
have one athletic
bone in my body.
So what to do?
So what I ended up
doing is channeling
this competitive drive into
games, every kind of game--
board games, card games, video
games, jumping rope games,
although that did test my
dexterity a little bit.
But all of these games.
And I realized that
there's a lot that we
can learn from playing games.
But something happened
to me in middle school
and into high
school that happens
to a lot of little girls.
We start getting
socialized to tamp down
our competitive spirit.
And then in addition
to that, many of us
didn't grow up
playing team sports
with at least the intensity or
frequency of the little boys.
And I'm going to put the
big disclaimer on right now.
I've spoken to a lot
of mixed audiences,
and I realize that I
am generalizing here.
Lots of little boys didn't
grow up playing sports,
and lots of girls
made Olympic teams.
But overall, when you take a
snapshot of the marketplace
today, this is what it is.
So we didn't learn how to
play team sports growing up.
So what ends up
happening is that you
come into the workplace
as adults, men and women,
and your points of view
on competing, and winning,
and losing are very different.
And so what the book does
is it bridges that gap so
that it can help the
reader to advance.
And it's really interesting.
All this being ladylike at
work, it plays itself out
in a lot of subtle ways,
and it plays itself out
around gender
roles specifically.
So I thought it was intriguing
that a couple of weeks
ago, Michelle Obama-- she
gave a commencement speech.
And she said in
talking about her work
as First Lady-- she was
reflecting on it, and she said,
was I too loud and emasculating?
Was I too soft?
And so you have
the highest office
in the land, the most senior
woman in the world, arguably,
and she's thinking about it.
And I'm sure she's
thinking about it
as she's raising her daughters,
what this all looks like.
And so it's a little bit of
a muddled mess, if you will.
I remember when we
were starting out HGTV,
and I was having drinks one
night with a girlfriend.
And she was in
business, and we were
talking about this
whole new business
that I was on the
ground floor of,
and I was going
to help to create,
and my career, and
all these things.
And she stopped, and she
said, you know, Susan,
you're really ambitious.
And I had one of those
moments of, well, that's rude!
But then I thought to
myself, now wait a minute.
I mean, even I'm
buying into some
of this double standard stuff.
So it does befall us.
And advancing, as we
move up, it becomes
trickier for women because
of all kinds of things.
And we'll get into that.
So I am not suggesting that
women act like men at work.
That would be really
counterproductive.
But what I am suggesting is
that you think like and act
like an athlete would.
And I had to learn this,
because I wasn't one of those.
But by that I mean
composed, confident,
having mental
fortitude, thinking like
and acting like a winner.
And you may have
heard the phrase,
you fake it till you make it?
I did a lot of faking
it along the way--
not feeling like a winner
but acting like a winner.
Because I realized that,
especially for women,
we're looked at and
scrutinized a little bit more
than the guys are in terms of
whether we can carry ourselves
as leaders.
And trust me, I'm half
Greek and half Italian.
None of this came
easily, but I learned it,
so I know that the reader can.
And hopefully you all
will be reading the book,
and if it is an issue for you,
you'll be able to learn it too.
So the 10 strategies
under gamesmanship.
The first seven are skills and
behaviors, and the last three
deal with emotional maturity.
And that takes us
from worker to leader.
So I'll go through
each of these.
Conditioning, just
like an athlete
needs to condition
their body for game day,
so too do we need to have
conditioning skills if we want
a senior leadership position.
And again, another
disclaimer-- not everyone
wants a senior
leadership position.
I get it.
But if you do, here
are the three skills
that I write about
in the book-- line
experience, financial knowledge,
and having a global view.
So what's line experience?
And I have to tell you, I've
done a lot of universities
with this talk.
And this is the one that really
resonates for young adults,
because it's not something
you necessarily think about.
Line experience,
these are the jobs
that directly impact the
profitability of your company.
Usually, there's a revenue
component attached,
but not always.
So sales is the easiest one.
It's clear.
It's a line job.
Marketing can be a line job.
It's a little grayer.
Products jobs, where you're
creating products and creating
services to push the
profitability of your company--
all of those are line jobs.
And in my book, I've got a lot
of different examples of it.
So if you want a
senior position,
having this operating and line
experience is very important.
So that's what that's about.
Second, financial
knowledge-- I did not
have one finance class in
undergraduate or graduate
school.
I learned it all on the job.
But what happened to me is
in middle management, when
I was at CNBC, somebody handed
me an income statement, right?
And I went uh-oh.
I need to learn this.
So I asked to be sent somewhere.
So they sent me to UVA
Darden, and I was there
for a week or two,
taking some finance.
And I learned enough to get by.
And then once I was in my
job, I became more conversant
because I was speaking
to shareholders.
And I needed to be
more conversant.
So this is all stuff you can
learn, especially if you're
a publicly traded company.
It's all there.
And you don't need to understand
the SEC rules of reporting.
Your accounting people do that.
But what do you do
need to understand
is what's an income statement?
What's a balance sheet?
Because these are the
language of business.
And the third one,
a global view--
I started the international
department at HGTV,
and traveled the world, and
learned how important having
a global view is.
This helped me to
appreciate diversity
beyond gender
diversity, diversity
that's cultural diversity
around the senior table
and how important that is.
So this is another one
that, for all of you who
are thinking about
senior leadership roles,
I mean, clearly
the world is where
we're going to be pushing
our top line growth.
OK, so those are
conditioning skills.
And see?
I'm going back.
I thought I wouldn't
be caught up.
OK, let me push forward here.
Composure.
Composure, and I talked a
little bit about this earlier.
So composure is both
how we carry ourselves
and how we communicate.
And in terms of how you
carry yourself, as a woman,
there is more scrutiny
about whether you
can make-- it's all about
how we're so emotional.
And because we're
so emotional we
can't make
well-reasoned decisions.
And so how you carry
yourself is very important.
And I had to learn this
one, as I said earlier.
Deep breaths.
In the book, I talk
about all kinds of ways.
Sleep, getting enough sleep.
These kinds of things
really impact whether or not
you're going to be
composed on the job.
So that's carriage.
And words, it's
kind of interesting,
but McKinsey did a study.
And they said that, on average,
women speak 20,000 words a day,
and men speak 7,000 words a day.
And so you wonder why we
have this communication gap
sometimes.
And what it is is
brevity, clarity.
These kinds of things I learned.
The easiest thing for me was
to just talk, talk, talk, talk.
But I was always with men.
My whole career, I was side
by side with men, not women.
And so I could tell
when I lost them.
I mean, it didn't
take much for me
to get the guys to tune me out.
So what I had to learn is how to
be crystal clear, and just very
less is more.
Brevity is more.
And I want to read-- one
of the women I interviewed,
Pat Mitchell.
She was the CEO of
PBS and a number
of other media companies.
And she worked for Ted Turner.
And I don't know if you've
all heard of Ted Turner,
but he was Turner Broadcasting.
He's kind of iconic.
So she's describing
her first meeting
with Ted, her first
on the job experience.
And she said, the first
meeting I had with Ted,
he cut me off after
about three sentences.
And I thought, wait a minute.
I'm not through.
I did all this work.
I've got all this
presentation done.
I'm ready to tell you more.
And he said, I'm not
ready to hear it.
Meeting over.
I was so upset.
I went back to my office and was
writing my resignation letter.
Because I was thinking,
I'm 40-something years old.
I've been in this
business 20 years,
and I'm not going to have
somebody just say no.
Then he called me on
the phone, and he said,
I know you're upset.
Why are you upset?
And she said, because nobody
since my father told me no
and they didn't
have to explain why.
And he said, well, that's
just the way I operate.
I'm going to be very decisive,
and you'll get a yes or no.
It's just the way I operate.
And she finishes the story
by saying the training
I got from him was invaluable.
I learned how to present my
case very quickly and very
succinctly.
And speed's our
enemy, and so that's
another reason why our ability
to be very clear and brief
is important.
So that's what
composure is all about.
OK.
Rule three, offense.
So playing offense,
if you're an athlete,
is scoring points
for your team, right?
So playing offense
for a company is
scoring points for your company,
making money for your company
through deals, new partnerships,
new products and services.
All of these are
playing offense.
So playing offense is showing
your company the money
you can make for them.
Which always reminds me of
a clip from an old movie.
Have any of you seen
"Jerry Maguire"?
OK, so I'm going to set
this up for you in case
you don't remember.
Jerry Maguire's lost
all-- he's a sports agent.
He's lost all of his clients
except one, Cuba Gooding, Jr.
And Cuba Gooding, Jr. knows he's
got Jerry by the short hairs.
Showing your company the money.
And that's what offense,
playing offense is all about.
However, see, one
of the funny things
that can happen with
women is we have
to ask if we want
to be successful.
We have to ask for resources,
for people, for technology--
all of these things
to do the best jobs
we can do for our companies.
But how we ask-- see,
there's lots of B words
that can be assigned us, of
which boss is the nicest one.
So how we ask
makes a difference.
And in the book, I
talk about something
called artful assertiveness.
So that's a way of asking that
doesn't break somebody's back.
And this is how I
learned about this, OK.
So it was sort of
fed back to me.
A woman named Robin and I
had-- let me set this up.
So I had to assign offices
and cubes for everyone
at HGTV, which is a miserable
thing to have to do.
There is no winning in
that kind of a thing.
But anyway, I did that.
So Robin knocks on my
door, and she says,
Susan, I want to talk
to you about why I got
a cube rather than an office.
And OK, go for it.
And she proceeds to
tell me about her job.
So she said, my job, one of
the things that I do is train.
And training is going to be
noisy, because I'm in a cube.
Another thing that
I am responsible for
is partnerships, which are
confidential conversations.
I'll have to find some privacy.
So she had four or five
reasons, all of which
were for the good
of the company.
There wasn't one moment
where I heard whining.
You know, Johnny got an office.
Why didn't I?
None of that.
Nothing was personal.
And so what I learned
from that experience
is what I call
artful assertiveness.
So you have to ask,
but always frame it
like it's good for the company.
And you can do that, because
if you're not asking something
that's not good for
the company, then
you're probably going
to get a no anyway.
And that's just a really
much easier way for you
to play offense.
OK.
So brinksmanship strategies.
This is the game
of negotiations.
And I've always been chief
negotiator at every company
I've ever worked with.
And it was so kind of Jeremy
to say that I was always
into win-wins.
So here's the difference.
I negotiated with
men my whole career.
And my experience
with men was they're
into win-lose, no hard feelings.
Women are into win-win, but
there usually is a lose.
And when there is a lose,
there can be hard feelings.
So how do you bridge that?
And I want to show
you a piece of film
from a movie from
a couple of years
ago called "Arbitrage"
with Richard Gere.
I don't know if any
of you saw that movie,
but he's trying to sell his
company to this gentleman.
And he's not moving
fast enough, so he's
called this breakfast
meeting to see
if he can get some resolution.
It may be a little extreme,
that piece of tape, but I mean,
I know if I was sitting
in that restaurant
and watching those
two, I would think
that they despised one another.
And at the end of that,
they both shake hands
and say they made a good deal.
So that is one thing I learned.
It's that in
negotiations, there's
a lot of what I call theater.
And it's too bad,
but it is what it is.
And once you realize
that, then it
becomes much easier
for you to do deals.
Now, I talk about four key moves
in negotiating-- the walk away,
the bluff, sizing up
the room, and the tell.
And they're all
from playing cards.
I mean, playing poker?
I learned all of my
negotiating strategies
from playing cards and poker.
But the walk away's the only one
I'm going to talk about today.
The walk away is folding your
hand if you have a bad hand.
We have to be able to walk
away in a negotiation.
Otherwise, it's
not a negotiation.
We're negotiating
against ourselves.
So always ask yourself.
If you are in a
position where you're
being empowered to negotiate for
your company, what's the floor?
If you know what the floor is,
it's really easy to walk away.
And this is what
I would always do,
is I would go to my
management, and I'd
say, OK, what's the floor?
What's the range?
And then once I knew that, I
walked away plenty of times
from deals.
And somebody would call me
back, and we would reengage.
But you have to be
willing to do it
And I'm going to read
one other excerpt
from the book, a woman named
Ronee Hagen I interviewed.
She was CEO of Polymer, which
is an industrials company,
multi-billion dollar company.
And she told me this
story about walking away.
"I was recruited to a
position, and the company
made me an offer that I thought
was below what I was worth.
I told them they had
a wonderful company,
but I would not be interested in
the salary range they offered.
I then offered to give them some
less experienced candidates who
might be interested
in the pay level.
In less than two
hours, they came back
with a much richer offer.
The biggest negotiating
leverage you ever have
is to be able to walk away."
And ladies, we're still
$0.72 on the dollar.
So when you're negotiating
for salary and compensation,
you have to be
willing to walk away.
And I realize that
we need jobs, right?
We have to pay our bills.
But this is just an
important principle
that I want to leave with you.
The rest of these things you
can read about in the book.
OK, fan clubs.
This is the essence of it.
if you don't remember anything
else, the importance of fan
clubs, and by that I mean
building a network beyond just
the four walls of
your department,
the importance of
building your network.
And this is one that I think
men do a much better job
of than women do.
And I learned to do
it by watching men.
Your supervisor is really,
at the end of the day,
not all that important
to your career.
Which may sound crazy, but
they're only one person
in your company, right?
And it may be that they
review you and all that stuff,
but what's important is
getting to know others
in your company who can
help you to advance--
building a network.
Success and likeability are
positively correlated for men
and negatively
correlated for women.
Stanford research, it just
keeps being validated.
And I could stand
up here and tell you
all the reasons why that is.
I don't think it's
important why it is.
What's important is
what do you do about it?
And what you do about it
is you build a network.
And you do that by taking
somebody to lunch or coffee,
asking for somebody's
help that's
not in your four walls
of your department
that can help you
with a project,
signing up for cross functional
teams and task forces.
All of these things get
you outside the confines
of your job and help you
to build relationships.
And those are all important
elements of advancement.
Oh, I've got to talk
about that for a second.
So this is the media, of which
I've been a part all my career.
They're some of
the worst offenders
when it comes to women and
issues around women leaders.
So this was the headline
when Marissa Mayer first got
into her job at Yahoo and had
her first earnings report.
"Yahoo CEO's Pregnancy
Overshadows Flat Revenue."
When I saw that, I was
just flabbergasted.
And that's the media.
And I wrote a letter
to the editor, which
of course didn't get posted.
But it made me crazy.
OK.
So build your network.
Six, practice,
practice, practice.
Some of you may have read
the Malcolm Gladwell book,
and he talks about 10,000
hours to be made an expert.
That's a lot of hours, right?
I mean, your career is a
marathon, not a sprint.
And when I work
with young adults--
and I have a 24-year-old, so I
know a little bit of what goes
on-- there's an impatience.
And I get that, because
I'm sure that when
I was in my 20s and early
30s I was impatient too.
And I wanted to keep
moving, and I wanted
to have a lot of career growth.
But the fact is we want to
be X before we're prepared.
We want to know why
before we've learned it.
And it just takes time.
And so I would ask all
of you to just-- I mean,
you're at a wonderful
organization.
Have fun.
Enjoy every day instead
of always thinking about,
well, why aren't I this,
or why aren't I that?
Because your career
just takes time.
I was 39.
I was COO at 39, which
in traditional business
is pretty young.
And I was too young.
I had a lot of growing up to do.
So these things take time.
Cross training.
Yeah.
So one thing that I
advocate in the book
is called cross training.
And by that I mean
lateral moves.
There is no longer a
ladder up to the top.
It's more like a jungle gym.
And lateral moves
are broadening.
I did a bunch of them.
When I was in my
20s for HBO, I was
in four different offices
with the same job,
just meeting different clients.
And I did a bunch of them.
And people within
SNI, the company
that I helped to co-found,
they do it all the time.
And many are sitting around
the executive table now.
Lateral moves, think about that.
It's broadening.
I have not met
one CEO who is not
a broad composite of skills.
So something to think about.
OK, suit up.
This is a light chapter.
It's about wardrobe.
And I wrote it and thought
my editor would just toss it.
But she not only
kept it in, what
I have found is
every interview I've
been on with this
book, even CNN asked
about this chapter on wardrobe.
So I guess it's still
on people's minds.
And there are a couple
of things that I
recommend in this chapter
for women in wardrobe.
One is not to dress
provocatively.
Now, I mean freedom of
expression and all of that.
But I've had plenty of
conversations with women
about what they're wearing.
And a lot of times, you
just don't even realize it.
Not dress provocatively.
There's no such thing
as provocative dress
for men, ladies.
If you walk into a
meeting and a man
has three buttons
unbuttoned on his shirt,
he's probably one
of my relatives.
No one cares.
But if it happens to you, it
could really spell disaster.
And the other is-- and I'm not
going to get into this story.
This is a very
embarrassing story.
It's in the book-- about the
need for full length mirrors.
So invest in full length
mirrors, and actually use them.
Because they can come in handy.
OK, so those are the seven,
a very abbreviated form
of the seven rules.
And the last three are about--
it's part two of the book.
It's about emotional maturity.
And I could spend another
couple hours up here on that.
In fact, tomorrow
I'm giving a TED talk
at UCLA on emotional maturity.
There's a lot to say.
I use three metaphors
in sports language.
One, about good sportsmanship.
And I talk about, I tell
stories about people,
including me, who
lost jobs to others.
And by handling the
whole thing well,
it ended up being wonderful
for our respective careers.
So good sportsmanship.
Grit, which is
essentially resilience,
being able to push through
fears in tough life situations
to get to the other
side, and look
at what the learning could be.
The worst thing is when
you're in the middle,
and you're paralyzed by it.
So pushing to the other side.
And then team play,
in which I talk
about things like the importance
of girlfriends, which I forgot
as I was making my career rise.
And the other things I
talk about in team play
is importance of culture.
And Google has a very
pronounced culture.
And you're either going to
love it working here or not.
It was the same with
places I worked.
There was one place I worked
I talk about in the book.
The culture was terrible,
and I had to leave.
But here's the great news.
And I'm going to tell
it by way of this photo.
So we're the founding
team of Home and Garden
Television and Scripps
Networks Interactive.
We called a meeting before
we were even on the air.
And it's probably the
most important meeting
we've ever had.
This picture, by the way,
was taken last August.
We were celebrating 20
years of being on the air.
And we wanted to define
the work community.
We wanted to figure out
how we were going to engage
with each other successfully.
And words like-- we ended
up with core values.
Core values like work-life
balance, diversity,
shared responsibility,
compassion, support--
many of these that may sound as
if they skew gender female are
the core values of the company.
And trust me, there was a
lot of debate about those.
But what I learned
is that because I
had a seat of
authority at the table
I could help to influence
the creation of a culture
that today is very inclusive,
radically inclusive.
In fact, I have a quote from
Richard Rohr, whose book
"Rising Upward," in it, in he
says, "Those who are not true
leaders will just affirm people
at their own immature level.
And of course, immature people
will love them and elect them
for being equally immature.
If you have grown
in maturity, you
are able to be patient,
radically inclusive,
and understanding."
And today, the senior table at
the company I helped to create
doesn't look like that.
It's about half
male, half female,
with two people of color.
We're still working
on that part.
So I know it can be done.
You can create these
kinds of cultures.
But you have to have
a seat at the table.
So the book is about providing
some strategies, insights,
hopefully a little inspiration
to help you realize whatever
your career dreams are.
So that's it.
And now I guess we'll go
to Q&A if there is any Q&A.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for being here.
That was really great.
You had mentioned that when
you were 39, you became COO.
And you said that was too early.
Were there-- now that you
look back, are you like, god,
I wish I'd just come
two years later,
and I would have been
so ready for that?
Or are you happy that it
happened that way because it
just forced you to grow.
SUSAN PACKARD: Yeah.
It's a great question,
and it's timely.
So these were the guys that were
surrounding me when I was COO.
And many were a little
bit older and a lot wiser.
So because I had this
incredible team around me,
I was OK in saying
yes to the job.
I knew that I'd had the support
I needed to make it work.
But that's something you
have to take into account.
Who are your teammates?
Who can complement you?
And no one is everything.
So you have to have people
help and complement you.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a follow
up to that same question.
Sorry.
How do you know
that you don't know?
How do you know that
you're not ready?
SUSAN PACKARD: Well,
for me, it was just
a question of when I would
go into an experience,
a new experience, with
business, a meeting
or a strategy question.
Not so much strategy questions,
but more life experience issues
and people issues.
So for example, one of
the things we did early on
is we flew a lot of
people and their families
to relocate to Knoxville,
Tennessee, which
is where we're based.
Small town.
And some of these
didn't work out
So here we've relocated
an entire family.
And it was really-- those were
some of the hardest things
that I ever had to deal with.
And so I learned
from that experience,
really the only way you can
know what you don't know
is to just try it.
And yeah, upon reflection,
what did I do right
and how could I have
done that differently?
But you have to act.
I mean, the most important
thing-- all of you
are entrepreneurial.
You're at Google.
Always take action.
Don't get stuck in the muck.
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
It was great.
I guess my question is
a lot of the rhetoric,
as I understood it, was you
have to play the game in order
to get ahead.
How can we change the game?
What are some steps
we can take to make it
so that I can have three
buttons on my shirt
unbuttoned without people
judging me or judging
my ability?
SUSAN PACKARD: Right.
I know you were being
facetious there,
but I'm not sure
that'll ever change
when you're working with men.
But this is why I
ended with this story.
So ways for you to get advanced
in companies like the book,
like cross training, like
more skill development,
once you get a
seat at the table,
you can change the culture.
But you have to get
a seat at the table.
So that's what the
book's all about.
You guys, it'll
be faster for you.
You won't have to
be 39-years-old.
But you might have to be
35-years-old or older than you
are right now to get
that seat at the table.
And you're going to
change it that way.
A lot of students, when I
go to different universities
to speak-- Stanford,
one of the students
said that he hopes that his
CEO will be 23-years-old.
And I said, it's going to
be a pretty unusual CEO that
can be 23 and do what
needs to be done.
It just takes time to grow.
So changing it from
underneath, you
have cultures that
are so hard to move.
But you can create new cultures.
You're welcome.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming.
There are so many ways
to approach this issue.
And I like yours, because
it's digestible and something
we can do ourselves.
And I was an athlete,
so I love this.
But this has been a
hot topic for a while,
and recently I've seen
things coming out.
They're more systemic solutions.
Get the men involved.
Change the whole culture.
Change the work
policies, et cetera.
And that seems a
little different
than your suggestions.
So what do you think about
those systemic ideas?
SUSAN PACKARD: Right.
It is all of the above.
Diversity Core, I read
about what you all
are doing with that.
And that sounds like
a wonderful program.
Programs inside the
organization are very important.
What I was saying is just
from a pragmatic standpoint,
to be able to help
that change, I
believe you need to be seated
in a position of influence
in the company.
And you can participate
in these systemic things,
but eventually, when you get
to even manager level, where
you have some people
that you're managing,
all of those ways of you to make
a difference in the company.
So it's all of the above.
It takes all of the above.
One of the things
I did at SNI was
I created flex policies there.
They didn't exist.
But I was in a seat of
authority to do that.
But it doesn't
mean today you all
can't tell your management
this isn't working.
These flex policies or
whatever it is, job shares,
telecommuting.
Some of these things
can be difficult.
You can talk to your
management about it,
but I guess what I'm saying
is the easiest way, believe it
or not, is to advance
yourself in your company
and to get in a
position of influence.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SUSAN PACKARD: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
Everything you were
saying rings very true.
And I've heard women
say time and time again,
well, we can't win.
I'm just here to have fun.
I'm not here to win.
Well, of course
you're here to win.
Why are you playing in the first
place, is my response back.
But you lay things out very
simply with the 10 steps.
And I was wondering
how you contrast
that to something like
Sheryl Sandberg's "Lean In"
and the difference you see
there in what your philosophy is
versus what she had put forth.
SUSAN PACKARD: Right.
I thought her book was
great, and her book did
a lot of focusing on our
self-defeating behaviors
and how we can overcome them.
And what I was trying
to do with this book
is to provide an offensive
strategy, if you will.
Instead of focusing
so much on how
we're defeating
ourselves is to say here
are all the things we can
do to get into positions
of advancement in companies.
And it's my take.
I mean, there are other
books with other takes on it,
but this was my experience and
validated by the CEO interviews
I did.
So I guess it's the
difference between a focus
on self-defeating.
That's not all she
does, and we should.
I mean, that's important.
But also an offensive strategy.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
SUSAN PACKARD: You're welcome.
Yes, Jeremy?
JEREMY STERN: So you've been
on this whirlwind book tour
now since February?
SUSAN PACKARD: Mhm.
JEREMY STERN: Been all over the
country to some amazing places.
What's resonated?
What have you found has
resonated with your audiences
about the book and
about your message?
SUSAN PACKARD: While I've
spoken to mixed groups,
the majority of the groups
I've spoken to are all women.
And when all women
are together, there's
a real let down your
hair kind of thing.
In the book on the
chapter on grit,
for example, I talk about
some very difficult situations
I had in my 20s.
One was being
assaulted in a hotel.
These kinds of things
that getting together
and to talk about those things
from a practical standpoint?
I mean, who teaches you
how to travel on the job?
Nobody taught me.
And so I was really naive.
And when I've talked about
those things on the road,
and we've had open forums
to talk about them,
it's been remarkable how
quickly women have responded
with their own
thoughts about how
they need to have
safe kinds of systems
in place for when they
travel and hadn't thought
about it before.
Line experience I
mentioned early.
Not something that anyone
young in their career
had really thought about.
So I think the things that
have resonated for me the most
is to be able to provide a
little bit of new insight
to the audiences.
And I've been really pleased
with what I've heard back.